justice shall fall upon the world men
the Army's right and shadow will collide
across the fields of eternity
[Music]
more than anything Diablo 3 eternal
collection proves just how well
blizzards action-rpg has aged six years
after its original release the dungeon
crawler remains as rewarding as ever and
despite a few technical concessions it
has found yet another welcoming home on
Nintendo's portable console for those
unfamiliar with blizzards 2012 loot fest
Diablo 3 places you in the shoes of a
super-powered demon slayer in a hellish
gothic world you explore five disparate
regions from a top-down view upgrading
your character and earning new loot as
you battle the lords of the underworld
and their monstrous swarms with the
eternal collection Diablo 3 includes
every expansion every character every
quality of life improvement the RPG has
ever implemented one of the more notable
options here is the ability to play
adventure mode right from the start
eliminating the need to slog through the
slower paced story out of necessity of
course incoming to Nintendo switch
Diablo 3 has also become a portable game
and it works it works incredibly well in
fact I can imagine few games better
suited for a handheld port so much of
Diablo 3 plays best in short bursts from
the 10-minute chase for that next
legendary item to the satisfying flow of
a challenge rift it's another testament
to the novelty of Nintendo's console yes
but also the elegance of Diablo 3's
design as was the case with Diablo
threes previous jump to ps4 and Xbox one
the mechanical leap to switch is
painless and fluid it's still just as
easy to rely on muscle memory while you
focused on the kaleidoscopic display of
magic and fire when it comes to visual
fidelity Blizzard ensured that Diablo 3
on switch runs at 60 frames across the
board
aside from rare occasions when elemental
effects didn't animate on screen the
eternal collection is remarkably clean
the frame rate is equally stable in
handheld mode and online and crunching
those mobs is just as satisfying as it's
ever been
the eternal collections resolution on
the other hand is a bit more muddled in
the switches dock mode Diablo 3 looks
aggressively fine or at least as good as
any other six year old isometric game in
handheld mode 720p resolution how
things get cloudier there's a slight
haze over everything making character
models look more like mirages than
actual figures handheld modes jagged
edges and foggy panoramas aren't massive
flaws by any means but after playing for
long periods in docked mode they tend to
stand out what they don't do however is
detract from Diablos
thrilling combat and of course in true
series tradition that combat is often
more thrilling with a friend or too few
cooperative experiences compared to a
monk demon hunter barbarian and wizard
working in concert to whittle down mobs
one demon at a time it's a special
thrill to see my character build factor
into a larger group and an even better
one to see how that group dynamics
subtly changes how I play as with
previous console iterations of Diablo 3
the eternal collection allows up to 4
players on one console at a time item
management is less satisfying in this
scenario as you're either a quick
equipping new loot without appreciating
its subtleties or pausing the game for
the entire party just so you can boost
your damage by 100 points the radial
menus are also still as imprecise as
ever but I'm hard-pressed to think of a
better solution without a mouse and
keyboard the eternal collection brings
the additional ease of playing via land
connection on each player's respective
switch it's helpful to have the camera
focused solely on your character
especially in Diablo 3's more hectic
moments but I still couldn't help
preferring local co-op there's something
novel even nostalgic about playing on
the same screen watching the same chaos
unfold as the person next to you
regardless Diablo 3 on switch allows for
several methods of playing with friends
and whatever your preference might be
the experience still holds up like the
best games Diablo 3 has gotten better
with time and despite a few setbacks the
switch is now my preferred home for the
extraordinary RPG it includes every
major improvement Blizzard has made to
the formula with the added handheld
versatility every switch port offers
Diablo 3 is a game about long-term goals
accomplished in short thrilling bursts
I have spent six years enjoying it and
will likely spend 6 years more I came
into the eternal collection expecting a
eulogy for one of my favorite games but
instead I stumbled upon a celebration
[Music]
you
[Music]